[Musique]
bonsoir nous avons toujours tort
d'essayer d'avoir raison avec des gens
qui sont convaincus qu'ils ont toutes
les bonnes raisons de penser qu'ils
n'ont pas tort raymond devos artiste
célèbre pour ses jeux de mots on choisit
rarement
c'est supérieur ses clients ses
collaborateurs
alors comment on peut communiquer avec
eux au mieux beaucoup vous diront en
maîtrisant l'art d'avoir toujours raison
ce soir je vous dirais le contraire ce
serait plutôt en maîtrisant l'art du
dialogue
l'univers de la communication évolue à
pas de géant depuis des décennies et
pourtant nous n'avons jamais assister à
autant de désinformation et de confusion
nous n'avons jamais autant assister à
autant de colère de frustration et de
violence entre les individus
comment ça se fait c'est uniquement
parce que les gens ont peur de s'écouter
nous ne nous agrippons bec et ongles à
nos opinions afin de coûts créée de
créer un bloc auto protecteur qui nous
permettra de gérer nos peurs de
l'incertitude
voilà si vous devez retenir qu'un seul
une seule phrase ce serait celle-là
quand j'ai débuté ma carrière en 2011
j'ai coaché j'avais pour clients parmi
des mes premiers clients des politiques
je vous promets que ça m'a beaucoup de
challenges et côté écoute il fallait pas
que je succombe à mes peurs en les
entendant me parler des enjeux et des
risques pour la tunisie le fameux
syndrome de facebook on va tous mourir
je l'ait vraiment vécu également il
fallait pas que je succombe au plaisir
d'écouter leurs anecdotes concernant le
monde politique étant une passionnée moi
même alors comment faire
apprendre à écouter quand ça fait pas
partie de notre métier c'est pas si
facile parce que si c'était si facile
nous n'assisterons pas à ce combat de
coqs bien de poules d'ailleurs entre
politiques dans les médias eux qui sont
sains s'est même montré le meilleur côté
de même au moins pour ne pas se faire
élire pas pour se faire élire mais au
moins pour faire adhérer les citoyens à
leurs idées nous n'assisterons pas
également à ce dialogue de sourds entre
syndicats et gouvernants eux qui sont
responsables de nos vies et de la vie
des futures générations
nous n'assisterons pas également assez
divorce sanglant entre adultes
consentants et nous n'assisterons pas
également à cette rupture
générationnelle et art chic dans le
monde de l'entreprise
d'ailleurs que l'on essaie de réparer
avec l'intelligence collective en
boostant dans les organisations
l'aco réflexion je ne peux pas oui ce
qu'il faut comme en faire il faut
d'abord une prise de conscience je vous
demandais de penser à vos conversations
est ce qu'elles ont plutôt le rythme
d'un match de ping pong balle après bâle
où votre seul objectif est de gagner
point après point
c'est ce que disent tous les coachs
sportifs ou bien ça ressemblerait plutôt
à un match de golf un tournoi de golf où
les joueurs
effectivement vise le même trou mais
savent qu'ils ne vont se réunir qu'elle
a remise des prix observée également les
gens autour de vous est-ce qu'il vous
enseigne plutôt les règles du pin pon
bien les règles du golf
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt le contraire
le vrai dialogue et là je parle du
dialogue fertile pas dû
ping pong de d'opinion et de cours et
activités que l'on essaye de faire
passer pour convert pour dialogue
aujourd'hui
non je parle le dialogue c'est un
équilibre entre écouter et parler mais
c'est également de s'offrir le luxe
inconfortable de changer d'avis en quoi
c'est un luxe inconfortable
zaïm dire essayer de demander un
syndicaliste un homme politique à des
couples ne pensez pas aux scènes de
ménages juste d'émettre l'hypothèse de
changer d'avis lors d'une conversation
avec en jeu c'est exactement comme si
que vous leur demandiez d'aller
volontairement se battre contre un
ennemi mais sans arme sans armure et en
laissant de côté leurs connaissances et
leurs certitudes
c'est dire dire le combat interne que
l'on peut vivre alors nos opinions
ça on peut les on peut dire que nos
opinions c'est comme des programmes
informatiques dans nos têtes et ces
programmes vont vraiment tout faire pour
contrôler nos meilleurs prendre le
dessus sur nos meilleures intentions
ils vont même jusqu'à en créer d'autres
la tunisie a eu un prix nobel de la paix
grâce à la l'organisation du dialogue
national
eh oui donc c'est dire quand même les
vertus du dialogue
j'entends déjà vos silences et vos
sourires vous comment on fait
précisément pour dialoguer jeu on va
prendre l'exemple d'un chercheur
scientifique en bon scientifique quand
il a une idée dans l'esprit il va faire
une expérience et il va observer ce qui
va se passer
et en général ce qui va observer
et toujours similaires et non identique
à ce qu'il avait dans l'esprit et du
coup il ya une nouvelle idée qui va
survenir
parce qu'ils auraient constaté des
similitudes et les différences
donc on va assister à l'émergence
continu de nouvelles idées et du coup
c'est là où une nouvelle idée une
nouvelle expérience
une nouvelle observation et nouvelles
idées alors là c'est le dialogue d'un
scientifique avec lui-même
oui on peut dialoguer avec soi même
d'ailleurs je vous promets que tous les
conférenciers ont beaucoup dialoguer
avec eux mêmes ces derniers jours
comment ça se passe quand on dialogue
avec l'autre c'est exactement le même
processus vous allez entamer une
conversation vous allez mettre de côté
le bloc auto protecteur et vous allez
écouter exactement comme le physicien le
chercheur pas le physicien le chercheur
scientifique va observer son expérience
ensuite vous allez répondre avec cette
nouvelle qu'on verse à cette nouvelle
compréhension et du coup au fur et à
mesure que le dialogue va progresser
vous aurez un flux d'ide et innovante
c'est comme si maintenant je vous
demandais de changer les règles du ping
pong d'un commun accord bien sûr ou
premier raid personne n'essaie de gagner
deuxième règle si quelqu'un se trompe
tout le monde y gagne
du coup vous allez passer d'une posture
de gagnant perdant à une posture de
gagnant gagnant
alors vous allez me dire ça c'est dans
un monde parfait
c'est vrai on n'a pas tous l'occasion de
dialoguer avec des gagnants avec des
gens en posture gagnant gagnant mais
pour ça vous avez le choix soit de
d'arrêter jouer ne pas jouer carrément
au ping pong avec ces nouvelles règles
ou bien de dire que de toute façon en
gardant ma posture le dialogue s'en
portera mieux
même si l'autre à une posture de
gagnants perdants et
ce qui est sûr c'est que vous mettrez
par en colère et vous ne sentirez pas la
frustration c'est pour cela que je me
demande qu'est ce qu'on attend de faire
sortir le dialogue du placard et de
l'intégrer parmi les disciplines
indispensables que sont l'écriture le
calcul et la lecture
cnn a fait une expérience à mener une
enquête
elle a posé la question savez vous tenir
une conversation professionnels sur les
3300 57 personnes questionnées 30 % ont
répondu non on aurait pu avoir une
fabuleuse conversation avec une poignée
de porte
48 % ont répondu oui mais c'était un pur
hasard 22 % ont répondu non je panique
je bégaie et je suis carrément nulles
encore une motivation pour apprendre dès
le jeune âge
l'art de la du dialogue et la compétence
de lait coûte alors ce que je voudrais
vraiment vous faire passer comme message
c'est que la communication d'homme à
homme et la huitième merveille du monde
qui continue de se reproduire à notre
insu à travers le dialogue et nous
sommes tous responsables de la
sauvegarder dans ce monde en pleine
mouvance le diallo pourrait être la
colle ou le ciment qui rassemblerait les
individus et les sociétés
merci
[Musique]